oh you've redecorated I don't like it so
we got a clip for the upcoming Doctor
Who Christmas special and I I was
determined to not watch it because it's
it's you you may have heard if you watch
mine on Doctor Who videos that at this
point once I know I really want to see
something aside from a first trailer I
try to cut myself off from the marketing
like I went to Thor Ragnarok only having
seen that first trailer I have only
watched the first full trailer of I
actually mostly was first full truths
the first teaser trailer for Star Wars
the last Jedi I've cut myself off and I
was determined to do the same for the
Christmas special but it's it's Doctor
Who I couldn't stop myself so might as
well talk about it now this clip it gave
us a little bit of interaction between
David Bradley and playing the first
doctor and of course Peter Capaldi
playing the twelfth doctor for the last
time sad but in any case we get a little
bit of their dynamic their interaction
and for this bit it's not unsurprising I
mean the doctor it's kind of traditional
that most of the time when the doctor
initially runs into himself there's a
bit of not necessarily antagonism but
like they don't hit it off right away I
think the ones who did work maybe 10 11
but even then they had to have a little
bit of a sonic screwdriver measuring
contest so I mean that's pretty
traditional so I think this was a thing
that was it was a very safe thing to put
out there as a teaser cuz it doesn't
feel like it gives anything away because
it's the kind of interaction that we
really expect I mean to the point that
you almost wonder would it be better to
play against that do something really
different except that I think we don't
be really disappointed if we didn't get
something like that
especially knowing how grumpy the first
doctor was so it feels good and it feels
true to that I I find it interesting
that we do actually find out now a
location for the for the setting of this
Christmas special I again I have been
trying to avoid knowing a lot about it
going in so I don't know if this was
revealed before but um
it's South Pole during World War one a
new world war one well I didn't know if
it was 2 or 1 I had I guess I gathered
from people who know uniforms better
than me that they identified that
characters uniform the one played by
Margate is as being a world war 1
uniform where I personally couldn't tell
one way or the other so I knew that that
was gonna factor in some way but I
really coming off of the doctor falls I
was really convinced that he was meeting
the first doctor on the 10th planet you
know on the you know right before that
the first doctor's own regeneration
happened I was so certain that was going
to be the case especially coming off of
him on decipherment egg calendar but
then oh so we're on earth at the South
Pole during World War one okay and I
thought oh that that look of that though
the wheels turning in Mark Gatiss his
head when he was told World War 1 and
him following down the Strand and his
head of what that means was that was a
sad moment and he plays it well I
actually at least as far as Doctor Who
is concerned specifically I like Mark
Gatiss as an actor better than as a
writer I think the best writing I've
seen from him was on Sherlock I haven't
loved his writing on Doctor Who but I
like him as a performer and he actually
seemed to be bringing more pathos and
more humanity to this part that we
usually get from him he usually does
kind of slimy skeevy he's he's good at
that but this so this feels like a
little bit of a departure for him I
guess I'm not sure what else there is to
say like I said the the interaction
between Capaldi and Bradley is good
there's a good sense of rhythm and
comedic timing I like how it's going
back and forth between the first
doctor's annoyance at what he's seeing
inside the TARDIS was I'm burgled and
and this poor World War one officer just
you know having the normal amazement and
just sort of fading back between the two
of them with this guy in on and then the
first doctor just annoyed I it's hard to
tell if this clip is intact and by that
I mean I I have to wonder if it's
slightly shortened for the purpose of
only having a two-minute clip and maybe
there's a bit more back and forth
they kind of removed out of this eye
that's possible I don't know if that's
the case I'm going to assume not but if
if that is not the case if this is an
intact clip they they have the first
doctor up to speed that that he is
encountering himself pretty quickly
which I like sometimes that can be
dragged out not the doctor who is
dragged it out exceptionally but in
general in fiction when there's like one
care to know something expects the other
to figure it out it or know it let's
drag this out doctor who did that not
with the doctor and himself but it did
it more in husbands of River Song I'll
call it paid off well at the end of that
episode it is it's a thing that gets old
overall I liked this clip but I and in
the timing was interesting for me
because I actually have only recently
started to get me I try and really ramp
up getting back into filling the holes
in my knowledge of classic who and some
first doctor stories is is some of the
stuff I've started with there there is
going to be more cut sort of coming down
the line in relation to that but will
will get that'll be for another time
but for right now having them recently
just taken in some first doctor stuff
David Bradley is as good in the actual
part as he was playing the actor who
played the part before in adventures in
space and time so this I think this
could potentially be a really nice and
just a pleasant send-off a nice
Christmas episode will we'll see the
Christmas episodes can sometimes kind of
get torn between trying to be light and
fun because it's Christmas and
especially with something like this that
also needs to be a good buy I hope there
isn't a tonal clash from that and they
can deal when they can have both and
have them both live in the same space
but we'll see um but this clip cool I
like it so those are my thoughts on the
clip that was released for the upcoming
Christmas special of Doctor Who did you
see it what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the council
podcast available on Apple podcast and
stitcher radio I am also one half of the
punch like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the firewater podcast
network Fire and Water podcast comm
latest episode just drop so why don't
you check it out it was a review of Thor
goddess of thunder vol 1 so give that a
listen links for everything is down
below and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]